do you want your kids to fight not at
all not at all not at all you know I
mean I was I even with my my sign mother
I was telling her I like I don't want my
son to fight you know I mean he's so
intelligent right now and the bangs were
he even he because I'm one of my
daughters didn't grow up into boxing but
she was still young she was by about one
I so when I started really getting into
it
that was my oldest daughter but she
knows so much about she used to daddy
traveling yeah going going different
places and stuff like that but the rest
of the kids they they you know they grew
into this all right now yeah that's all
they know so especially my youngest son
you know he used to sleep with socks on
his hand
yeah that would have been his glassing
gloves so time you teach the kids at
preschool comes be like dad yeah you
know he's our juniors we're too so you
know he you know he looked at it he
loved it he understands that mikey is no
stubborn and I'll call you Tom dad you
know this is my thing though with your
kids and their dad being the heavyweight
champ and I said people you know have a
20 month old son do you know you wanted
to find what no no there's no world
champions grown sleep in satin sheets
Malibu California and world champion
will come out of Malibu they don't come
out of their dad making you know seven
figures you're not gonna get that that
this this pressure and the the dynamics
build this diamond into this world
champion my kid just he's incoming with
something else
smarter than his dad right he doesn't
need to fight fighting for you know for
a lot of people that I didn't you know I
didn't have a lot of other options right
there's a ton of options and it makes it
more personal when you try to fight out
of poverty you know you have something
to fight for is something there's no
plan B is nope no plan B I mean anyone
Plan B's get beat up badly
bad hear me and when we have our kids
and be able to provide them provide for
them in a certain type of way what they
fighting for why would they do that you
know me
it's like with my son I always tell
people I sacrifice for do karate boys
you don't have to make this walk you
know me so but I also told her that my
son's mom
so if he wants to do it and I see it in
him he's driven and he's passionate
about it didn't that's another thing
genetics no there's that where he might
just be this freak this be like alright
I know the business I don't want you get
hustled if you're gonna do it at least
let me you know walk your hand into the
gym there's that cuz he's gonna be a
nice-size kid yeah I mean so hopefully
hopefully you don't want to do this this
is a dangerous sport and I always say if
my mentality if somebody else had the
same mentality like I have fighting them
then it's trouble I'll tell you this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue good what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]